what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
characters teams and concepts from
across the county book industry and this
week we're counting down one of the most
requested videos since this concept came
into existence the top 5 Deadpool
moments in Marvel Comics starting off
our list in the number 5 spot is
Deadpool's confusing conversation with
loki during Deadpool's art of war
deadpool somehow ends up in the past and
kills sunsoo the famed writer of the
book the art of war realizing that the
book can be used by turning it into a
manual on how to run a business
Deadpool approaches a publisher only to
be told that the art of war as a
business manual is no longer relevant
since everyone's already done it seeking
to bring the world to the brink of chaos
in order to sell the book as a manual on
how to survive the end of the world
Deadpool meets with Loki in order to
instigate a war between Loki and Thor
that will spill over onto the planet
Earth and hopefully lead to its ruin
what follows is an absolutely confusing
and hysterical conversation between the
two where Loki keeps saying I a term
used to mean yes while Deadpool believes
that Loki is referring to himself
eventually things seem to get settled
enough and Deadpool continues on with
the plan as it was made by Loki coming
in at number four is Deadpool spoopy
face his Deadpool spoopy fingers I can't
believe I'm doing this thing in 2014 in
this story carnage begins yet another
series of murders based on his insanity
while flipping through various channels
Deadpool we seize what appears to be a
series of short messages and comes to
the belief that fate is telling him that
he can track down carnage and bring him
into his insanity the result is that
during their first conflict carnage
bites off some of Deadpool's fingers
Deadpool tells carnage not to worry
about it as they'll grow back but but
should carnage poop them out too just go
ahead and flush them down the toilet
it's this ridiculous oh my god rounding
out our list and the number three spot
is Leroy Jenkins a little-known but
absolutely hilarious moment came during
Deadpool solo Series in 2008 when Daniel
Way gives us
an event where Deadpool prepares to go
toe-to-toe with Big Bertha from the
Great Lakes Avengers taskmaster and an
assortment of other Marvel characters
but unable to figure out which one to
beat up first
Deadpool decides to take them all on at
the same time reciting the infamous
phrase from the greatest World of
Warcraft video of all time what do you
think of dual kin getting a number
control quick uh yeah give me a sec I'm
coming up with thirty two point three
three repeating of course percentage of
survival onslaught better than we
usually do already guys oh my god he
just ran in number two on our list comes
during Deadpool Herald of Galactus in
this story after spending a majority of
his money on guinea pigs
Deadpool finds himself completely broke
and in need of work after attending to
become a sidekick in order to kill for
various villains and even Ironman
himself but being turned down by
virtually all of them Deadpool answers a
classified ad on behalf of Galactus who
needs a new Herald after a quick
interview process Deadpool is made
Galactus Herald and sets out into the
cosmos in order to find planets that
Galactus can consume unfortunately
Galactus got a little more than he
bargained for when he realizes that
Deadpool is called the Merc with a mouth
for a reason he just won't shut the hell
up after growing tired of hearing
Deadpool's non-stop nonsense Galactus
eventually fires Deadpool giving him the
shortest tenure as a Herald of Galactus
and the history of Marvel Comics second
only to the golden oldie Aunt May the
final moment on our top 5 list of
deadpool moments is Deadpool's pancakes
this moment comes and Deadpool volume 1
issue number 16 when he's recruited by
the x-men in order to bring Deadpool
into their ranks Cyclops sends the
superhero Domino in order to meet with
Deadpool what she finds however is a
Deadpool is lying in wait as soon as she
arrives Deadpool holds her at gunpoint
instructing her to take several steps
back eventually she falls to the glass
below her feet causing her land on
372,000 pancakes that dead
had previously made after Domino's
initial anger subsides Deadpool and
Domino share pancakes together with
Deadpool accepting the offer to join the
x-men but only under the condition that
he gets aware the x-men uniform that he
made for himself complete with his own
name written on the back so there you
have it my top 5 pick for Deadpool
moment so with that being said I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
let me know and I will catch you guys
later